is there data on the intelligence the iq
of parents
as it relates to the children yes and
there is some evident genetic evidence
of kind of a
of of an interaction
between the parents iq and the
environment that high iq parents provide
an enriched environment
which then can
impact the child in addition to the
genes it's that
environment so there are all these
interactions that you know um
but it's not you know
think about the number of books in a
household this was a variable that's
correlated with iq
and and it is yeah well what well why
especially if the kid never reads any of
the books it's because
more intelligent people
have more books in their house
and if you're more intelligent
and there's a genetic component to that
the child will get those genes or some
of those genes as well as as the
environment but it's not the number of
books in the house that actually
directly impacts the child so the two
scenarios on this are you find that
and this was used to
get rid of the s.a.t test oh the s.a.t
score is highly correlated with the
social economic status of the parents
so all you're really measuring is how
rich the parents are
okay well why are the parents rich
yes and so you could the opposite
kind of uh syllogism is that
people who are very bright make more
money
they can afford
homes in in better neighborhoods so
their kids get better schools now the
kids grow up bright
where in that chain of events does that
come from
well unless you have a genetically
informative research design
where you look at siblings that have the
same biological parents and
and so on you can't really disentangle
all that
most studies of social economic status
and intelligence
do not have a genetically informed
design so any conclusions they make
about the causality of the social
economic status being the cause of the
iq
is is a stretch
and where you do find genetically
informative designs
you find most of the variants in your
outcome measures
are due to the genetic component and
sometimes the ses adds a little
but uh
the weight of evidence is it doesn't add
very much variance to predict what's
going on beyond
the genetic variants
so when you actually look at it in in in
some and there aren't that many studies
that have genetically informed designs
but when you you do see those the genes
seem to have an advantage sorry for the
strange questions but there's is there a
connection between
[Music]
um
fertility or the number of kids that you
have
and g factor so you know the kind of
conventional wisdom is
uh
people of
maybe is it higher economic status or
something like that or having fewer
children
i just loosely hear these kinds of
things is there is there data are that
you're aware of in one direction or
another on this
well
strange questions always get strange
answers
yes right uh so yeah do you have a
strange answer for that stranger the
answer is there used to there there were
some studies that indicated the more
children
in a family
the
the firstborn children would be more
intelligent than the fourth or fifth or
sixth
it's not clear that those studies
hold up
over time and of course what you see
also
is that
families where there are
multiple children four five six seven
you know really big families
uh
the social economic status of those
families usually in the modern age is
not that
high uh
maybe it used to be the aristocracy used
to have a lot of kids i'm not sure
exactly but there there there have been
reports uh
of uh
correlations between iq and fertility
but i'm not sure that the data are very
strong that the firstborn
child is always the smartest it seems
like there's some data to that but i'm
not current on that
how would that be explained that would
be an uh a nurture
well it could be nurture it could be in
uterine
environment i mean
the biology is complicated
and this is why this you know like many
areas of science you you said earlier
that there are a lot of gray areas and
no definitive answers
this is not uncommon in science that the
closer you look at a problem
the more questions you get
not the fewer questions
because the universe is complicated
and the idea that we have people on this
planet
who can study the first nanoseconds of
the big bang
that's pretty amazing
and i've always said that if they can
study the first
nanoseconds of the big bang we can
certainly figure out something about
intelligence
that allows that
i'm not sure what's more complicated the
human mind or the physics of the
universe
uh it's unclear to me
i think we over this is a very humbling
statement
[Laughter]
maybe it's very human-centric
egotistical statement that our mind is
somehow super complicated but biology is
a tricky one to
unravel consciousness
what is that
that's well i i've always believed that
consciousness and intelligence are the
two
real
fundamental problems of the human brain
and i and i and therefore i think they
must be related
you